- Hello, I'm Patti Harrison.
- (sighs) And I'm
Joel Kim Booster.
- You're a ******* bitch.
And your watching Unsend
where we celebrate the best
and the worst of the web,
but mostly the worst.
(energetic techno music)
(crowd cheering)
(paper crunching)
- This issue needs
to be addressed
as quickly as it
needs to be stopped.
Hot girls on Instagram
taking way too many pictures
of themselves eating junk food.
(chanting music)
Are these biddies
Papa John influencers
or am I missing something?
Why so much pizza?
- I'm sure you've all
picked up on the fact
that I myself am a hot,
hot little slut girl.
- Hmmm.
- But when I eat pizza, I
just suck it all in, okay?
I don't invite a glam squad over
and take a bunch of
pics of us squattin',
popping in squats, eating
and licking on pizza.
- And there's the
time Sarah Hashcroft
made a shocking announcement
in her photo depicting
her eating Fruit Loops
whilst wearing a bikini.
"Buy me a box of Froot
Loops and I'm all yours."
- Girl, a box of Froot Loops
is 2.50 before coupons.
What are you doing
with your life?
You're supposed
to be influencing
and this is your self-worth?
Two dollars?
Two dollars!?
- Our society is crumbling.
First gay marriage and now
model is eating Froot Loops.
Also, how come her body looks
wet, but her hair is dry?
I need answers.
- Hot girls of Insta,
stop pretending like
you're doing us a favor
and trying to come across
as relatable or people.
Olivia Holt doesn't even put
cream cheese on her bagels.
She's going to be an
active shooter very soon.
- Her Instagram page
looks like it's showcasing
Christian Bale's diet for his
role as Dick Cheney in Vice.
Olivia, stay in your lane, girl.
(paper crunching)
(swipe)
- We've all sent
something, said something,
tweeted something that
we wish we could Unsend.
- Today, Esther Povitsky is
gonna share her shameful Unsend
because the only way
to Unsend an Unsend
is to talk about it.
- Thanks for being here, Esther.
- Thank you for providing
me with a platform
to tell this story that
I'm going to regret telling
for the rest of my life.
A long time ago, I had
started dating someone new
who was a little bit
out of my league.
I'll say it.
- In what way?
- He was tall and handsome.
- Tall doesn't necessarily
mean handsome though.
Do you just mean he was tall?
- And any man who meets
my eye level here,
I'm, like, fine.
And any man who meets
my, when I talk to you
if my eyes do, like, this.
I will kill for you.
(laughter)
You're my god,
I'll kill for you.
But if you're here
I'm, like, hey.
- So as this strong, smart,
empowered business
woman that I am,
I was, like, he's
out of my league.
I need to figure
out how to keep him.
I'm just gonna see if
squirting is real, right?
- I don't know, it might be.
- [Patti] Yeah.
- Look, was I super thin
and had a great bod?
Not really.
Was I a tall, classically
attractive, beautiful woman?
No, I wasn't.
I was just me.
- On a mission to squirt.
- Yeah.
- That's really romantic.
- That's beautiful.
- It is romantic.
- I'm gonna ******* cry.
- So, I de-pants, I
de-pantie and I go in.
I'm poking, I'm prodding,
I'm pointing, I'm laughing,
I'm smiling, I'm crying.
Hopefully, I'm squirting,
but I'm not sure.
- There's different
wets that can come out.
- Yeah, I don't
haver that knowledge.
I don't have that
experience, I'm.
- There's a lot more room
in there than I thought.
- So (laughs).
- Wait, how much room do
you think is in there?
- I don't know, I thought
it was mostly like a butt,
but in the front.
- And then I remembered that I
had a pretty close friendship
with a woman who was in porn.
Who better to ask?
I have a direct line of contact
with someone who
actually knows this
as opposed to doing all
this Google searching.
So I text her and
it's a long text.
Do you know, we're
talking a true paragraph.
I told her that
there's a liquid.
I can't quite tell
is it maybe piss.
Maybe, so I include
that in the text.
I hit send, she responds.
I open the text and it
says, "Who is this?"
(sighs)
And I just never responded.
And, look, I can tell you
who I am any day of the week.
(whispering)
- Esther, that's so, so sad.
- [Esther] That's strange.
- But if you just
receive a text about me
possibly pissing myself
in my twin sized bed,
I cannot tell you
my name after that.
And I think that's fair.
- I'm not using this
as a pejorative,
I just think you
are mentally ill.
- I think that I
was in my early 20s
and those were the same thing.
(drum cymbals crashing)
- Joel, baby.
- What, no.
I don't, what's going on here.
I don't trust
whatever is happening.
The last time you
were this nice to me
you stole my identity.
- That instinct isn't wrong.
I'm about to destroy you.
Here's the thing.
Here at Unsend we
poke a lot of fun
and we enjoy taking the piss,
so to counteract that
snark, I dug around the web
to find something that will
grab you by the lower intestine,
push up through your throat
and spill out your eyeballs.
(emotional music)
(crying)
(cat meowing)
- Are you identifying
with the cat in this?
Is that why you're sad?
- Yes, the cat, it was sad.
- It was sad because
three people died
in that apartment fire and
they glossed right over that
to focus on one cat.
You let them die
because they were gay.
He's a homophobic
firefighter who loves cats.
Do you feel good about
your tears now, Patti?
- Wait, how did you
know they were gay?
- Because I could
sense them dying.
Something that a lot of people
don't know about gay people
is that when another gay
person dies we feel it.
- That's the same
for trans people,
but it's, like, anytime you
see someone else get, like.
- Okay, let's not make
this a political show.
Everybody at home,
this is Patti Harrison.
- I've been silenced again.
- And his is Joel Kim Booster.
And we're Unsend.
- We're Unsend.
- We can do better.
We can do better than that.
(quirky jazz music)
(paper crunching)